last year in London there was the
equivalent of a moped moped enabled
criminal attack every half an hour
clearly fed up Scotland Yard's scorpion
pursuit teams have released footage of
their new policy to deliberately mow
down moped riding suspects during
high-speed chases so far officers have
not 63 such riders down even when
they're not wearing helmets there is no
upper speed limit for this measure and
it's called tactical contact it appears
to have reduced mobility acts by over a
third now putting aside my concerns over
disproportionate force for now what
about the rest of us at risk of being
caught in the crossfire in 2016 police
police pursuits led to the deaths of 28
people surely there must be better
technological solutions available police
are already using Stinger devices wait
for it
and the forensic marking of Murph is a
sharply reduced theft releasing footage
in this way it makes me feel incredibly
uneasy there's something to dystopic
about police celebrating mowing other
suspects one not nervous or celebrating
just let me talk explain what tactic
what tactical contact isn't a minute
however I think the people of this
country will be cheering from the
rafters on your very radio station guys
talk to 43,000 people and 91% of them
totally agreed with it you know the
police here are damned if they don't
damage for years would be four we've
been having a go at them that they're
not proactively policing that they're
letting criminals get away with stuff
here now they're doing something
actually the disposal gets kept one
thing straight
when when the police get involved in one
of these chases the crime has already
happened and the police have told them
to stop if they choose not to stop they
choose what happens to them after that
when when if these people hope these
then they're scumbags these people if
they choose to steal a moped and to
drive it at innocent vulnerable people
the elderly young people if they choose
pregnant people if they choose to to
steal them to hurt them to mug them to
try and stab them well then they choose
the concert
winces of their actions hang on a second
let me finish it the consequences of
their actions are that the police drive
up to this visit and it's specially
teamed things they're called they're
called scorpion drivers they accelerate
when they get there they cut they take
their hand off the accelerator and they
put their foot on the brake and they
just nudge the wheel which puts the guy
onto the bonnet and it doesn't hurt it I
look I agree with you 100 percent of the
police agree 100 percent that the police
are caught between a rock and a hard
place I have every sympathy for the
police and I really don't care about the
criminals that's why I said I'm putting
aside anyway discern for the criminals
right worried about the safety of the
procedure and I do it I also understand
that before me the police weren't even
allowed to chase these suspects because
they if they weren't wearing helmets the
police weren't allowed to pursue them
right so we've we've gone from doing
absolutely nothing here we go see this
makes me very happy
yeah a video game yeah here we go this
is good this is a guy know what's this
one this is actually saying that what
yes there we go he's off he's all right
as well they're all alright nothing
happens to them and this is they're just
nudging the back wheel there we go is
the underlying issue here I tell you how
bad this has become now I live in a
relatively one of the safest parts of
London or this country and my teenage
daughter said to me the other day
earlier this year
daddy I'm scared to walk home from the
tube yeah and then she tells me stories
about what's happened to her friends
were chased by these moped gangs now
what does this country come to our
nearest police station has been closed
yes fifty percent of the public surveyed
recently have not seen a policeman on
their beat in a year what has happened
to that wonderful Bobby on the beat that
reassurance that you get just by seeing
somebody 20,000 the number of police
that have been cut since 2010 armed
police force you know that is less than
the level it was during the time I'm
saying but underlying this is the rise
in crime in fact this week there's been
a debate in the House of Lords on the
rise in crime and what are we doing
about it this is one attempt to do
something about it but the real the real
problem are the cuts the lack of
resources just can I just finish what
I'm saying but due to the lack of
resources as well because a lot of
police funding comes centrally people
are getting so DS criminal an answer the
scooter gang carry on we just have to
have the response from the police and
then of course you guys can carry on
hanging police commander has this to say
I think there's been a perception that
we won't intervene that if there is a a
rider who has removed a helmet what I
would say is is we will intervene and we
do intervene because we have to consider
the safety of that rider the safety of
the public and also the safety of our
officers right so I want to throw to it
after one second I just want to say that
I actually I agree the cuts are a
problem do you think cuts our situation
because you can see how having a policy
of not intervening if someone's not
wearing a helmet is a massive incentive
and I you know in my area which has
never seen this kind of crime before we
had one of these moped attacks they were
terrorizing mothers with small children
but you've got to think about the police
as well because this is something I mean
Carol you're presenting this as they're
kind of you know harmless cleaner did I
say that no one gets hurt and it's fine
what I said was no one has been ok well
let me tell you what the Police
Federation have said about this and
they're worried about it they said will
they and they're talking about their
officers be backed or will their
livelihood and liberty be put at risk
just by launching the pursuit police
officers take a risk there needs to be
protections around this afforded to our
colleagues both in law from the force
and with public political and media
opinion they are doing nothing more than
their jobs they must be back
protecting us here there's my concern
about this is that I think you can you
can't talk about this without talking
about cots to policing because because
what feels worrying about it is we've
moved from a time where there was a
police presence in your community and
there was intelligence-led policing and
the police knew what was going on in
there new people so a time when there
are no police and when something happens
they come in and do to use violence that
is not just try and wrestle it back oh
yes so we worked yet do you support this
tactic let's enter in a word yes or no
if they if they are supported if there's
because legally the problem of the
moment is it even an ambulance driver or
in a police chase yeah they are support
liable okay that's not fire in a moment
an opportunity to see George Osborne on
the pledge which I always look forward
to and after that I want detective Chief
Superintendent know was to tell us the
better technological methods that could
be deployed so we'll come to you looking
forward to that Detective Chief
Superintendent but this is some of the
activities that these people get up to
we're going to take you to the street so
here we go using the mopeds a young
woman there phone now this is actually
George Osborne this is George Osborne
the former Chancellor now editor of a
national home own evening newspaper he
goes and then these are people getting
away from a robbery
again using mopeds these are the sort of
people would be the sort of people who
God willing they won't attack your
daughter attack a God willing they never
do so talk us through these better
technological measures and I'll make it
very clear I've got no sympathy for the
criminal we saw there of course is
horrific and those do you get them yeah
so so the question is whether it the
cost the opportunity cost of this tactic
is worth some of the deaths that may be
caused that's my point
and that was my point in the talk up and
so there have already been well that's
the question is it worth the cost
yes we're having high-speed chases that
have no upper speed to keep his daughter
associates rific as that footage was
yeah it doesn't lead to death if trying
to stop that leads to death of innocent
bystanders is it a cause you said your
daughter's friend I actually interviewed
a mom the other day whose daughter had
her phone pinched in the street her
daughter now suffers from anxiety issues
she won't go into the street now
multiply that by and these guys have got
committing up to 30 crimes an hour so
we're not just talking this we're
talking let's talk
worrying about the perpetrators having
the people by hitting 30 people coming
out of the tube in the space alone in
the station nope it and the number one
number one priority of any government is
a security of its citizens and if your
citizens don't feel safe we are the
government is failing in its duty with
respect that's my point because I
wouldn't feel safe if I have to watch a
mother and a pram get knocked down
because of this sort of tactic and my
point is about the bystanders not the
criminals and I'm wondering whether
whether the anxiety you're worried about
is worse for you then the potential I
think that we're gonna have to do yeah
you could carry on discussing the
dynamic we could carry on discussing
this Chief Constable